previously on raft oh oh god oh no not
the other no not the other one
other one oh that was that was close all
right load up
there's a llama
oh got it I have a llama what are we
gonna name it Mommy uh maybe Lobby
milkers oh I found Bruno's saw
oh nice bear can I use a stone as a
weapon I'm really uh hammering this this
oh man it takes nine or so rocks to kill
a bear what do I need a goddamn machete
to get through this crap I'm learning
machete oh I have a machete and we need
to turn on a relay station or something
I did yeah the number is 4988 sorry is
it refer okay oh if I I'm gonna fall and
die I'm gonna fall and die
I'm gonna fall and die I'm gonna fall
and die I'm gonna fall and die
uh Bob if you were gonna guide someone
to get to the bees you're at there's so
much dirt in this cave we need to get
this dirt do you have a shovel you
remember where I showed you the bees
before Wade where I was like up there
across the way
also also down there no no it's
different I went down instead
accidentally and there were bees down
here
um for the sake of animals and stuff do
we need to get a shovel to come get
these dirt plots probably but I don't
have a shovel
I have a shovel how far away from the uh
ranch place were you Bob I went down the
hill from the wrench house and now I'm
by these all right like I could see the
the station that's by the wrench house
okay I'll try to make my way over there
but I just found more bees over here I
thought there were more bees so there's
two more grab the bees the bear is back
Big Bear Big Bear
over here and I'm only half Health now
oh another Bear's back yeah
cut it up
Dawn I'll rock you I'll rock you I'll
rock you
this bear literally will not stop
oh
man
and so on ah you all right yeah fine
this is fine the bear will not leave me
alone I'm I've I've encountered a
Relentless bear is it the mega bear
no it's just a little [ __ ] I don't
know where you are I'm in the ring in
the middle sort of running I'm trying to
find the boat back yeah I'm trying to
find that as well I'm at the top of the
boat Hill right now
I am standing by the sign in front of at
the top of the boat Hill uh oh uh uh-huh
hello hello hello well you don't have
the bees that the Earth he's probably
still up on the hill
um well I had to fight a bear I'm on my
way oh keep okay I'm gonna go make sure
the whole boat isn't being eaten by a
shark
it's fine probably it's not a big deal
just in case just in case okay I'm on
the
hill we came up from the boat basically
now all right so am Mark oh this might
be the opposite side from where the boat
oh boy okay oh boy
oh I buy the bomb of bear I'm by the
mama bear oh I know where that is I'll
just chill here then
oh the shark doesn't attack if you're
too far away that's awfully nice of it
and it's dead I see you Wade over here
where are you guys leading to back here
I'm getting them to get the bees just in
case we need uh or one of you getting
shovel do you have any shovel marks I
have a shovel yeah sure okay after we
after we're done here we'll go back to
relay six to get that dirt yes hey I'm
gonna do some maintenance stuff on the
boat
there learn that that's good
I might be leading us the wrong way Wade
damn it fuel tank done how's the Llama
oh llama don't look very happy hey
there's a bear film bear he's dead oh
Lamy is a little oh I think we actually
passed away come back this way Lamy is
unhappy
yo you big sad yeah he's a little sad
okay
unnecessarily hostile mommy is our
friend mommies are sweet are you looking
for lamies go to Lami distractible
podcast and use code Mark 10 my code the
hell happened you okay I thought I think
I went to default response
an encountered an algorithmic error and
just said the default right we started
customized personality for the fool
all right I'm reloaded I'm back all
right good to have you here Wade yes hey
this is the right place wait I only got
us lost once yeah why don't you drinking
bees oh hell yeah oh there's a bear wait
wait I thought I got the bees but then I
got the bear too
I prefer to fight in a really
counter-clockwise sort of motion
I have 23 bees and 18 Honeycombs on me I
put some on the boat already that seems
like enough all right how do we get to
the shovel land from here I have no idea
but we need to head to we need to find a
roadside and take it to relay six all
right well there should be a road sign
up at the top of this
[Music]
this right or this right there's a road
sign over there yeah these road signs
are real Handy hey relay six this way
oh my God
hey roadside man whenever you just stay
on the path it's amazing how it guides
you uh it sounds stupid
I haven't done that yet
it's been really nice I'm gonna be out
of water though so I'm gonna show you
where the cave and head back I can give
you a few mangoes to get you by
if you swim around the water can you see
if there's any Blowfish we can make
another yeah what do I need to do the
Blowfish I need the explosive powder
from the Blowfish which means you need
to kill it without it exploding
it's very far away or like one quick
stab and far away or I'll throw Bronx at
it if you can throw rocks underwater
that would be such a such an alpha strap
yeah well let me just show you guys what
it's all about
it's not the way that Mark and I took up
here so I hope this is the right way ah
damn shark's back looks like that ain't
happening circus no Blowfish for us one
llama's good enough for now right Lamy
right Lomi well do we want isn't this
the way back down to the boat over here
I have no idea you know what I think
this might not be where the boat is nope
there it is nope yep no I don't think
that's the side I came down I was like
oh this is the opposite but maybe
there's a way to parkour down I Believe
in Us worst case we just dropped to our
deaths now come pick us up wait I know
what to do come here what you do is you
find this little ledge right here
hug the wall oh it's fun
is this a good idea it's right it's fine
it's fine it's fine it's fine that's
fine I'm fine this is fine oh God you
guys good you guys good you guys are
kind of bear
um you guys gonna be good yeah come on
closer counterclockwise clockwise
well twice how wise are we
okay good now you guys don't sound very
wise it's good enough to like don't stop
me now though if we like go the wrong
way then we run into each other
operation shot of the dead and it'll be
clockwise
[Music]
um
we have to sing Don't Stop Me Now as we
beat it with our pool cues
I get that I get that I get that
reference I get that reference I kind of
get it but I also haven't seen that
movie in like forever that's my favorite
thing in the whole the old man they're
beating with the pool sticks and the
Jukebox just blaring Don't Stop Me Now
it was really good it was really good
yeah it was really good you see it was
funnier the more I explain it yeah
actually Mark can you shoot up a flare
for us real quick yeah let me pull that
out of my ass it's up here it's up we're
we're going straight toward it now
oh God why hey look a bear Don't Stop Me
Now I was such a good time see you see
how effective this is
so effective all right oh if I crouched
down inside of it it can't wiggle away
from me my Bears don't wiggle wiggle
they fold
keep going uh my dick goes jiggle jiggle
I'm bald I don't think that's right but
hey this is where the boat is see I
eventually let us kind of there sort of
I feel like we went the wrong way around
80 of the entire circle and could have
been here way faster and we've got extra
bear meat and leather food
and once we get the bear claws out of my
leg we can use those to make stuff too
yes then we can kill other things with
our bare hands and the bare hands
welcome back everybody hey did you find
any blow no I was busy I did like I said
I couldn't I don't remember why I
couldn't but I really couldn't oh you
guys want to see the animal pass you're
upstairs not really he's pretty cool
he's pretty cool
he's pretty cool
look at how not dirt it is I know right
wait are you mad water in here what do
you mean it's a wiring for the bridge
you gotta put
I was laughing at wait I'm on your side
buddy okay good good
good see see who's on which side yeah I
see who's on two sides it's me on your
side thanks pretty cool right I'm on
your side and he's on that side and
eventually we're gonna see me make this
better yeah I do wait hang on wait oh
what are you doing what are you doing
today
I'm not sure yet hang on what are you
doing
what I'm having a forest flashback so
you guys don't have to make a hole
no no
no and like that okay great I did it and
nothing bad happened I don't know what
you did what did you did you'll see what
did you did
ah nothing bad happened that's for sure
do I need to research a honeycomb
uh I don't know mark look I here and
boom oh there we go that's nice let me
just water that black
perfect now you're so happy Lami how's
your happy llami
hey honey that's nice
Hi man behind
can we make the Beehive yeah
oh we need to be hives we need clay for
beehives do we have extra clay son of a
[ __ ] oh frick I'll get some okay should
we uh I can try to make a shark bait
that's sand God dang it
come here this is shearing time oh more
wool for me yeah how soon is that bait
gonna be in the water just curious I'm
throwing it right now excellent that's
clay I found clay hey you found clay hey
clay how many Clays do we need like two
oh wait that's the bait oh it was going
for the bait sorry Bob oh no oh four
it's four clay per behind 150 B jars per
Beat Bobby okay do you see what you do
to me Mark I see what I did to you I see
what happened Mark I'm sorry it's still
there I'm the bait I am the baker oh
okay okay okay okay this is still the
thing you did I swear I will avenge me
is he on the bait he might be on the
bait not yet but he might be okay that's
an important clear clear answer to give
on that one really crucial he might be
he might be not he's not he is no he's
not
okay good wait there's a shark attacking
we need eight clay I don't know if you
heard that I have uh three
um do we have any clay
anywhere okay
man we really should have been getting
clay
should have been yeah Shoulda Coulda
would have been
guys I just broke ground on the third
deck oh hell yeah those are all sand I
got a bunch of sand over here
oh hey God dang it hey what's up not
much just watching this shark eat bait
oh hey it broke the bait should I drop
another one oh yeah I know if you could
just maybe just do that real quick okay
if you could
um
hey guys I have seven sand is that good
that is very good
that's really good I'm super proud of
you I'm gonna make another oh there's a
hole where the engine goes
oh my God I just I just uh conf I just
uh he missed what am I trying to say
oh you're down there did you did you hey
get no whoa hey what's up what's up
what's up what's up and also no I did
not say it again how do I make bolts uh
one Metal Ingot Metal Ingot uh shark's
eating that bait
oh good excellent I almost instinctively
jumped down to try to check it
so you know I'm on the case oh good I
feel safe already good good good good
excellent all right well both of us down
here what are the odds the shark will
finish the bait ah
[Music]
I could try to smack it
oh it's done with the bait that's
probably fine you wanna make more bait I
don't know how
excellent me excellent all right I would
tell you there's a way to learn but I
don't think there is no there's clay
over here wait a minute anyway I might
have all the clay We need oh I'm here
with you I'll help I help it's cheap
right
eight that was sand there was one clay
and then sand son of a [ __ ] I have six
clay and you have one
yes that's seven clay ah
get it because of the Sesame Street okay
oh yeah the I only know of that from the
nipple Family Guy one the what one
nipple two nipples three nipples
I don't I don't know what that is what
is that it's where count chocolate
counts the nipples that's not his name
count
right you're struggling because his name
is the account Who the hell's count
chocolate he's a cereal guy he's the
cereal guy who's the mascot of the
cereal called gautocula that would do it
I never wanted never had isn't it
basically just like Cocoa Pebbles or
cocoa Crispies aren't those all
basically the same I don't know I've
only had yeah cool Pebbles I'm just
gonna say they're all the same
after me
you can suck on it and you won't be able
to tell if it's Count Dracula or Cocoa
Pebbles or what hey Bob there's a clay
under the boat the whole time I just got
son of a [ __ ]
don't worry I'm on the other side of the
planet swimming I'll be fine
I have 10 Clays in me oh Bob I'm sorry I
didn't mean to say it like that but I'm
very happy oh I'm drowning hang on
oh boy
I'm suspecting some things
no don't
oh my I'm no longer suspecting things I
was saying I bet
who the hell
wow that was quick oh it broke it never
mind I'm gonna say I didn't even get to
it
we showed it we showed it bro you have a
plank on you because this other one's
about to break too
guys did you know you can build
horizontal foundations and you don't
need to put pillars everywhere
you can do what with what you can build
horizontal foundations and you don't
have to put fillers everywhere
what how you can do cross braces
horizontally if you look in the pillar
menu and there's there's lateral ones
horizontal ones
that's not it
boy wow this is really not going well oh
man
I got stung by a shark that's not what
they do I got bit by a shark I didn't
really guys I got stuck by a shark and I
need you to just suck the stinger out
and just turns me on that one just trust
me oh I found a hole there's a hole in
the anchor part of the boat is there a
hole in the frog in the log on the bug
on the bottom of the seat yes we sing
that years ago we sang that we what so
yeah there was the the whole no maybe it
was the I threw a frog
that well you did that why do you think
that I thought that was a that was a Wii
I'm pretty sure it wasn't yeah oh no I
wasn't Mark there was audio of Houston
and I threw a frog yeah but you started
it that was all you I'm not very Musical
that doesn't sound right no matter it
wasn't very musical when it occurred it
didn't matter guys
shut you [ __ ] you don't you [ __ ] me [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you I I literally
think I'm lost swimming around the
island right now I'm on the bright side
it's around you'll eventually get one if
I don't what if I never find my way back
but I hope you have enough food and
water forever probably not
[Laughter]
I would have guessed I don't
that was that attitude yeah it's really
easy stop eating now I'll have enough
food yeah ration it a little bit damn
yeah damn this is where he keeps getting
those well you have a lot of Spears nice
Spears man thanks man take them I just
made one I kind of regret making now
come on take him he dares you take him
come on take him
take him I think I will this one's dead
I'll come take them no balls he won't he
won't
well that seems oh
oh no it's fine God damn it God
oh no it's fine
I think the shark's close to Dad do you
want me to murder it Bob to help you not
I he doesn't even I'm so far away he
doesn't even care he don't give a [ __ ]
about me okay I'm on the other side of
the universe swimming around like a dumb
[ __ ] ass face I guess whatever
ass ass face of hers I'm sorry this is
like a toy I would want what is that
ghost face the songs from Supernatural
is a fake ghost hunting team their theme
song was ghosts ghost face hers I just
changed it to ass faces because it made
me happy
I can see that no we can't have
happiness here you know this
especially not yours hey guys I'm
where the boat isn't are you on the
opposite side I'm at a fence by uh by uh
via beef but this is not the fence on
the beach where the boat is oh no can
you run across the island again
God I would say we bring it around to
you but you'd probably be faster that
would be a straight line I'll run
through the island I guess good meat or
good man good good me good meat cheese I
am good meat I hear that a lot of meat
oh hey Mark there's a shark on our boat
this is a shark this is a myth remember
that thing you didn't want to lose huh
what did we lose dude another corner
with the
nested
oh okay well it wasn't good I think
that's good
llama why are you sad stop being sad
will you get the big sad get over it I
made it back maybe nope this isn't the
right place hopefully our llama doesn't
need sunlight to photosynthesize it
doesn't actually yeah lame
[Laughter]
yeah alarmy but it's too many characters
so it's a zombie not lame hey guys
bringing a bear back to the boat I just
want to let you all know
we need this leather maybe probably not
guys I made it and it was all worth it
great nice congrats
ah who needs clay why do we need clay
here we go
oh cool what's that it's a curtain
[Laughter]
even you'd put that right there on that
wall
God damn man you that means so much to
me wait Mark you didn't even see the
feature of it look
it opens and clothes you know I did see
that but now that you've shown it to me
it's means so much more I just thank you
thank you you need to play to make some
B stuff yes right that's why we needed
all that stuff yeah for bees for engine
oil to make the make the dream come true
right for bees to put in the engine
right I'd forgot inside your legs this
bee is B clay thank you okay if you can
make the refiner somewhere relatively
close we can run a pipe right to the
engine we could but why would we do that
wait didn't we have a biofuel refiner no
we learned a biofuel refiner rewinder I
don't think we learned anything but we
probably did something like that we all
of a sudden are a lot lower on planks
what happened oh I built another level
oh I need about 40 of those planks back
if you could spare them uh
uh wait there's some planks though well
there's some amount of planks
oh you didn't check oh you didn't check
this one here here check out that main
main one there
four planks yeah that's what you use
that's what you said you needed right I
need 20 per beehive I really could help
I really thought we had an unlimited
amount we did when you were growing an
unlimited amount of trees well is there
anything else we need from this island
no we can go wood could we cut down
these no we can't cut down these trees
nah okay I need five planks to get the
second beehive done I can make one I
don't have that hey guys work
not going
where are we going I couldn't tell you
we stuck we are very stuck uh where do
you want the beehives at
um I don't know you can wear you can put
it up uh yeah up we could start that on
the third floor or I could modify we
don't need this big of a pen for Lami
but I was assuming we're gonna have more
do we need is this something we need to
harvest for it needs to be by flowers so
wherever it is we also need to have
flowers next to it so right you want to
do flowers on the top floor but then we
have to worry about birds no what we
could do is right down here uh what I
could do actually let me let me actually
do this we don't need this much grass
right so if I make one of these FL if I
make all of these flowers and then we
put 2B how big is a beehive it's about
one one spot biggest these plots okay
then one plot each right next to it in
the middle let me put one right here I
think so yeah plop or down here you know
I'm gonna drop it I'm gonna let you put
it that way you can see for sure how big
it is okay I mean no big deal for me bro
you're probably don't worry guys that
got us out of that thing we were stuck
in yeah that'd be perfect only kind of
yeah like that and then we'll put a
instead of Beats here I'll put flowers
here I can start actually that up we'll
have a lovely garden and it'll be
beautiful and if we get five more wood I
can make the second one
this is X
man I'd really love it if the wind
wasn't pinning us directly into the
thing
imagine do we have the right heading too
I'm just trying to get us going to start
collecting planks yeah I knew I knew I
kept all these flower seeds for a reason
I knew it I knew it
it's their time to shine it is it is
their time we're stuck on something guys
can I be totally honest with everyone uh
you're like yeah we are it's uh
oh God yeah we're getting unstuck this
way this is the correct way to unstick I
think I can't tell if that's sincere or
what but I really think no no that I
can't tell what we're actually stuck on
it looks like there's like a
it's just very shallow here
all the bees the bees are buzzing
they're so happy uh can I paddle I am
paddling it's not doing [ __ ] uh maybe if
we all paddle together just try and
paddle away from the island if we can
I'm dying of thirst oh our waters are
all empty oh no
I'll battle in a moment boys yeah I'll
help refill some water
oh we're loose we're loose we're loose
lads
keep paddling away from the island
quickly oh where's my battle
the sail is up we're still turning a bit
I mean the wheel is straight we're not
turning on purpose all right well there
we go we're free juice yes
back on the Open Seas once more
oh let's see is the life for me life
life life
let me plug in the new coordinates and
then we'll know where we're going
[Music]
4988 is the number
circuits really shoeing this battery
just died son of a [ __ ]
God damn it damn it make another I I've
stole one from the freaking thing
4988 one of you is like my brother I
won't say which one all right
there we go
uh we need to head south west oh that
means a lot Southwest we need to turn
left about 120 degrees I got you buddy I
gotta navigate the island here and then
we're gonna turn left and go that way
you said yes all right what about a
biofuel reactor I don't know what that
is we researched it I thought is that
the thing that makes biofuel yeah
biofuel refiner it uh actually it's
pretty simple let me see if I can make
it if we could do that uh we can we and
also if we can make a fuel tank uh we
can pipe up a system where the engine
will be fueled forever fuel forever
and we'll fuel the system with lard and
grease and lots of potatoes please
oh why am I full no uh maybe you
shouldn't eat so greedily unless hardly
true
all right second beehive acquired I no
longer need planks except for the grill
all right good good
well we'll start harvesting up again
don't worry any day now we're gonna
start netting up next to this one yeah
plop it right next that'd be good let me
know if we go upstairs and the llamas
just covered in bee stings and dying
that's fine that's why it's got wool
hilarious let's do it it does sound
pretty hilarious if I'm going to be
perfectly honest are you working on the
Bayou fuel Mark I am yes I just need
more wood all right we were so nearly
around the island almost I can't wait
for it so oh very almost I am so excited
well we actually need the Honeycombs for
now that we got the bees uh the
honeycomb is what you get from the
beehives as well you make the honeycomb
with glass into jars of honey and then
you make jars of Honey mixed with like
potatoes or beets or whatever into
biofuel mm-hmm and we need the beans to
make honey and we need glass to make to
make the jars of Honey gosh well we
should have plenty of sand right or do
we not uh I have 15 on me I could start
cooking that in a glass I guess no we
have glass I think I think we have less
there should be a surplus of glass well
we currently have 40 Honeycombs if there
is already glass there's glass yeah and
one of those there is some glass
somewhere right here in this second in
uh one there we still have nine clay
left over so how the hell do we spell
nine play did we have a bunch of Clay on
the boat that no one noticed maybe maybe
oh hey no I did my math right I don't
know where that clay came from I mean I
hate I came back with like 15 clay oh
that's why we have so much play then
okay so I only have use eight of it
we're nearly there on the bio refiner I
just got enough wood where are you
building it is that upstairs somewhere
no I have no idea I haven't even decided
on any of that oh you're just like okay
how much glass do you guys want me to
save you can build that on the top level
I don't think we need glass for anything
else important did all the Rope get
chewed up how did we get through all the
Rope we had so much rope there's no way
there's no way it's all gone no way
who's got the Rope
wait you're being quiet I got seven rope
on me I can put one of the things I have
a lot of rope but I don't have like all
of it here's seven it's in the middle
small container one
down there I have no idea how we chewed
up through all that rope very strange
you need it no I'm fine I'm fine I'm
fine I'm okay now I've got all that I
need six Honeycombs I offered it the
satisfy you agreed
I appreciate your song right now but
materials are sparse if we all get tired
I will lick your ass no help all right
yes okay no wait hold on guys you're
committed you're coming into little King
are buttholes you said it loud and proud
oh god what have I done
I don't know about that one
if I build it upstairs I could pipe it
directly into the thing there that's
what I was thinking I think if you can
build it right kind of where you are
build the refiner and then also build
the fuel tank up yeah we can pipe
straight down to it oh yeah actually if
you did it right literally right here if
the fuel tank could be here there would
be a straight pipe down to the thingy
okay right which would be cool you know
just two which is cool there okay fuel
pipe well now I can't see uh we can kind
of see okay uh should I start putting
honey in or something yeah go for it
you're finding stuff so the way the
refiner works is it'll spit out little
barrels of of biofuel you have to move
the biofuel from the refiner into the
fuel tank are you gonna be up here for a
while Mark uh I mean um maybe I don't
know if so but if not awesome what the
[ __ ] is it to you
don't look at me don't look at me don't
talk to me
and now I can put potatoes in there
no you you just put potatoes in and you
you put
uh beats in all the raw foods
okay and then the honey in the side and
it'll automatically make that [ __ ]
well I mean I can create a little chest
here and we can just put make it for the
honey oh yeah that'd be good uh oh I see
so the honey goes along with the other
material it's not its own okay yeah
exactly I'll put it right here for now
we'll probably eventually make another
one of these uh and then uh should
that's you know it'll make the stuff and
I'll put more croplets up here or maybe
downstairs just because it is kind of
nice having it underneath so that the
things don't NAB it things are going
pretty good yeah I'd say so what do you
guys think about maybe wrapping this up
and picking it up again later we made a
lot I was just thinking this might be a
good stopping point we just accomplished
a lot and we don't currently have
something big that we're doing yeah I'm
with you love oh no what is that oh is
that the Kraken oh